we got the story from willamette week
marchers
set fire to apple store and shatter
windows across downtown portland after
police killing
the scale of damage tonight recalled the
riots last may
here's what i love about this article
they say it's a riot last may
but right now they are marchers yeah the
media is absolutely shielding these
people but uh you know
that's for sure well i i think i was
trying to make the point kind of from
the other side which is
it's it's just as bad to then come out
there and and label every single person
who's out there in a situation where
you know police start banging up against
the front line of protesters they
declare unlawful assembly
some of those people were out there with
good intentions so if you say blm
terrorists in every single tweet then
basically you're throwing yourself into
that trench the other trench and so
you need people in the middle who are
just trying their their best to look at
both and say like
okay so we use the term protester
because it's like same as the capital
riot
there were certain people there who were
caught up in the madness the lord of the
flies effects of the chaos
you start getting pepper sprayed it's
pretty hard to make logical decisions
they didn't like so using that neutral
terminology wasn't good in the short
term i was like hey you're not going to
get as many retweets
but in the long term people started to
pay attention because they're like oh
these guys are actually here and they're
actually trying their best to actually
just show
fly on the wall what's going on how many
people are actively have you heard
actively call for the cops to resign or
leave
i mean that's that's a good point though
probably only me right yeah because my
position is i understand not everyone
out there is a violent terrorist
but there are many violent terrorists i
understand a lot of people go out there
and they're peaceful protesters
the problem with the leftist activists
is that they they espouse
a support for what's called diversity of
tactics have you heard this phrase from
the
from from antifa yeah diversity of
tactics basically means that if you're a
peaceful protester
you are supposed to defend yeah or at
the very least tolerate
violent extremists who are burning
things down and attacking police respect
the diversity of tactics it's an excuse
they have they have systems where they
need bodies you're right they exploit
that
that's for sure so but but so there are
regular peaceful protesters who go out
there knowing this and then say but i
had good intentions
even though i dressed in all black to
shield the extremists now what they say
about the police
is if if you have what do they say if
you have 1300
good cops and 12 of them are bad then
and the 1300 good cops won't call out
the 12 bad cops
then you have one thousand three hundred
and twelve you know uh bad cops i think
that's right one three one two
hey cab and so the point in the left is
making is the same
the cops who refuse to speak out and
stop the bad cops are just as bad
so i look at that and i'm like there's
no liter there's no legit solution
between two warring ideologies
convincing this that is evil
but there is one simple solution if the
people of these neighborhoods
won't defend the police that means the
police don't have their support
and if the the people and the other
people in these communities be it maybe
a smaller percentage
are actively voting against the police
yeah and the police
have a very simple answer instead of
arguing about who's evil and who's not
you leave you don't got to worry about
support you don't got to worry about the
violence and you don't got to worry
about
they asked for it they get it everyone
everyone's better off so my only point
is you're a commentator right so
your call for the police to do this or
that
that's legitimate our role here is to be
on the ground and to say what we're
seeing right
and so when you have the entire media
whose responsibility is to be on the
ground and say what they're seeing and
they're either
trying to portray this in this light or
this in that light i got my ass beat by
cops in wauwatosa with
a billy club and i showed the freaking
bruise on my knee and everyone's like oh
the bootlicker finally
it's like no no how many times have i
shown you know the
the blm snack van getting the windows
smashed in dc by this
white shirt cop who just decided to
smash a freaking window we're not like
choosing oh no the cops are good so
we're not going to post that one
it's like right that's but that's the
way that this should have been covered
from the start and the reason why we're
in this situation now
is because nobody was paying attention
to us because it was two different echo
chambers and
after time maybe some people are but
still you know
it's very much two different trenches
right i should i should qualify my
previous statement
when i said calling for police to resign
obviously the left is doing nothing but
that
yeah my reasoning is very very different
yeah yeah because they're being
sacrificed and disrespected and the
people in the community won't do
anything to stand up for themselves so
clarification understood but yeah so you
get
that's why i pulled up the willamette
weak thing marchers
set fire to an apple store they torched
that place it was gutted
and they're not marchers they're you
know what
i think calling the people who did that
rioters is being generous
yeah because they're political
motivations then
no a terrorist austere marchers
well um austere local activists well
while me and rich were on the ground
in in brooklyn center um i got i got
i caught a few interesting kind of
moments on video where you'll find black
locals from brooklyn center yelling
at white you could call them protesters
or agitators and tell them
we don't want violence in our
neighborhoods we don't condone this and
then and then tell them
hey when that that 10 p.m curfew hits we
all want to go home
because i think one one thing that maybe
a lot of folks don't know unless you're
on the ground and i try to
i try to put it out much as out there as
i can is what makes this situation from
brooklyn center police department
um difficult to control this crowd is
because right across the street
you have all these apartment complexes
so you have kids in these buildings so
that's one thing that we try to put out
is a lot of the the black locals in
brooklyn center literally came out
and we're telling the white protesters
hey don't be burning down our city don't
be doing this to our neighborhoods
we literally have kids here we have to
be here um until tomorrow so i think
that was an
interesting thing that uh i was kind of
able to capture we wanted to wanted to
put it out there or the guy's name they
have they all have
they were minnesota freedom fighters and
it was pretty funny to see the minnesota
freedom fighters predominantly black all
go up to
the antifa relegate which i've been
referring to as the umbrella gang
because you know
they're basically like rolling around
with their umbrellas completely in
formation the whole time
they're bringing like wooden barriers up
to the fence and stuff and the guys are
like
what are you doing yeah like we're out
here to protest
it's not to like smash with police like
we're trying to get our voice out here
what is your goal you know and then one
thing too tim is then the one the white
protesters of the antifa within
uh basically claim that the that the
black men of the black minnesota freedom
fighters
are uh uh working with the police and
they're getting paid under the table so
it was interesting to just hear that go
down in person
it's because you look at the data
peaceful protests work
it generates press coverage which
generates sympathy
and then makes political change it works
and
violent riots do the opposite like we
saw with the the civics poll
after george floyd's death net net
support for black lives matter reached
like 27
percent and then after the riots it
dropped lower than it had been the year
before
because people don't like writing i wish
people would realize that the best place
to peacefully protest is on the internet
on video in the 60s it was you got a
huge crowd so that hopefully you get
some media attention so people will come
with a camera and put you on tv on abc
news
you don't need that anymore now you make
a youtube video with 70 000 views
you change 20 000 minds and then
political change happens
well i mean i i think a good example
though is twitter activists took over
twitter and use it to ban people and
destroy the careers of those they oppose
it it was fully protesting i mean i
you know just from my outsider
perspective i mean it it could have been
even more powerful
like let's say when this george floyd
thing happened for them to say hey you
know what
let's get a million-man march in
washington d.c
we're going to go up and we're going to
demand these bills and we're going to do
it peacefully and
you know i think that would have been
more powerful and instead of the rise
because when the riots happen
then you know me and richard been on the
ground uh one thing that we try to do at
the daily caller i think
um you know not much folks did is after
the riots we would at least spend a
couple days like actually talking to the
business owners
and a lot of them say hey we supported
this movement from like day one
and now we're just we just don't
understand why and you just turn off
a lot of america when you go that
problem i mean like i said
i think outside of perspective probably
would have been more powerful to say hey
let's get a million people let's show up
in washington d.c let's march peacefully
and and you know let's demand
a set of bills and i think right now too
with black lives matter and t for
whoever you want to
uh categorize these groups is they don't
have a list of demands that's like a
legit like hey we're going off this
because you know when you speak to one
person once person says
abolish the whole system then some
people say oh we want some police we
want community police it's it's a
mixed message i don't believe i don't i
don't believe the businesses to be
honest
when i i've you guys have been to
berkeley i'd imagine right no yet
so in you go to you go to oakland you go
to berkeley go to the bay area
and all the businesses have these pro
leftist signs in their windows
one of them actually said i remember it
was a burger king and it said this is a
family owned
you know franchise please do not destroy
our windows see that
they had to say it outright because it
was a burger king you know the local
brewery just puts whatever leftist trash
in their window hoping that it
spares them so when you get it when you
get a journalist who comes out because
i've i've i've talked to people on the
record off the record i'll tell you this
on the record they're like we're big
supporters of the movement
just you know we're hoping that they
they don't destroy our business you turn
the camera off and they're like i can't
stand any of this what are they doing i
hate it
but they want to say it publicly because
they're trying to beg
they're begging extremists and i'll tell
you what happens this is the product
of apathy in politics the district
attorneys who get elected
are funded by leftist progressives
who will not prosecute their own so the
cops arrest them they get cut loose and
then they burn they set fire to the
police union building
then local businesses are forced to just
bend the knee because they have nothing
no justice system left to defend them
at what point is it a crime for a da to
release a criminal
i don't think i don't think it is i mean
like in los angeles right now they just
elected george cascone and he's been one
of the more progressive da's
and like i guess saying the l.a county
sheriff and him are just butting heads
on everything
i've actually spoken to a few police
officers and lapd on the record and off
the record who tell me like hey
some of the people that we arrest we
charge them for rape within like a
couple days
out on the street and they'll like
commit a murder so
that's it's just um you know i mean at
one point two you have to ask is like
you know what
at one point is it a crime because it's
like you're putting your own community
in danger and the people that you say
that you're protecting which is always
black and brown we want to protect the
black and brown communities that's what
you're actually impacting the most when
you do this is the black and brown
communities it's like they're not
getting they're not
these criminals are not getting released
in beverly hills i'll tell you that
no if they get arrested in beverly hills
they'll get shipped somewhere else
but you know who you know who seems to
have learned to give up because of
politics these da's they're like
whatever man
nobody actually cares about their
community anymore so i'll tell them what
they want to hear and then just do
nothing
and then all the cast happens like the
cops haven't learned yet they're like
i'm gonna keep doing the same thing over
and over again even though nothing's
getting resolved
but i guess hey when you're getting a
paycheck and you got a house you got a
mortgage payment
i suppose from my perspective
you know i said this two or three years
ago the escalation
i said i said this i think two years ago
that we were going to see
heavily racialized riots or riots for
racial reasons escalate because of a lot
of the critical race
and tim i wanted to bring this up too
because i know when we talk about this
stuff it's you know um
riots and stuff but i think one thing
too we maybe need to look at as a
society and i think maybe the adam
toledo
was a great ex not a great example but
something that maybe we could look at as
america is
you know what about the family structure
you know i think one thing that we're
not talking about
is is a lot of these people who are
causing the riots or out there you know
um taking advantage of of any civil
unrest um
what kind what type of family were they
raised did they have both parents at
home and i think that's another
discussion that america
needs to start having you know i know
with adam toledo yeah
but hold on to address that point you
realize a lot of these black lives
matter people are white progressives
from middle class families or upper
middle class families i think there was
a
but just because they're from upper
middle class family doesn't mean their
dad was in a [ __ ] bag
no i mean but their dad could be a lazy
middle-class
uh intellectual is that the right yeah
he could be a
huge wall street guy could be a huge
wall street guy who made them millions
of dollars you know and he's rich as
heck but his daddy was never there and
he's
so mad about it it's a good point but i
want to make sure we're clarifying that
it's not necessarily about whether you
got mom or dad it's about are your
parents
lazy and apathetic you could have two
parents
and they can just like they won't smack
you around when you're no no no
i mean like they send you they send you
to school
and then when you're begging for help
and attention they put you on drugs
yeah and then you grow up messed up
because you never had any real
leadership in your family i think we're
saying the same way
you're drunk but you like smack him
around like no no
oh you know come on i mean i turned out
just fine all right come on
i imagine it's easy for a dad to just
drink a
drink a few beers at night rather than
look as kid in the eyes
unfortunately yeah we need a dad who's
got like
you know he's doing like you know kung
fu and his his five-year-old son is
doing little kung fu next to him yeah
there's a video
i watched it was amazing it was this
dude and his like nephew i guess
and he's doing uh like some kind of
gymnastics training
and the little kid is imitating him and
then dude who's like probably 30 and
super rip does a backflip and the little
kid does a backflip and the guy lands
and looks
looks at this kid he's like whoa dude
kid just did it
because kids want to learn from you so
maybe yeah family structure is is
correct i just wanted to clarify
i think i think we need to bring that
conversation up with american politics
because
that's not talked about enough um i
think having the two-parent system
uh in the home i think all these things
did you just say
did you assume the gender of those
parents
no sorry about that but you know i think
i was like reading something yeah mark's
that time like don't cancel jorge
but i mean i think like i said it's an
interesting thing to look at because i
remember when i was covering the uh
you know riots in every different city
but specifically in portland i
that's one thing i kind of caught myself
is is you know when everyone's causing
destruction is to say
you know how many of these people who
are out here um grew up with
with just a regular family and and and
have a sense of purpose in life because
many of the people that i talk to they
almost have like no no sense of purpose
and when this george floyd thing caught
you know popped out they finally felt
they were part of a movement and they're
they were making a change
i don't know that's what i i think it's
been i think it's their dad's i think
it's mostly
the dad yeah you know no i agree so i
it's not so a lot of people like to
mention whether
you know people have dads or don't i
don't think that's exactly we we brushed
on this i think literally
yeah if you don't have a dad you the
studies show that there's going to be
actually i'm sorry i should clarify that
actually the studies have been
simplified to just two parents
a two-parent structure but i think if
people don't have a discipline like a
disciplinary
parent and i don't mean by like corporal
punishment i mean literally like
sit down son and you know met or sit
down you know daughter and
you know think about what you did and
you need a a
leadership role and a nurturing role in
my opinion i think there's probably a
lot of these these kids i mean you look
at these
kids it's like they've never left like
they've never picked up a heavy backpack
in their lives they're so scrawny and
frail
but they're angry they're really angry
and purposeless
so i i will say i don't think they
actually believe in anything
i really don't know some don't like i
said some the
some that i talked to in portland they
finally felt like
like this was their calling they were
they're part of a movie that they were
going to make a change
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you